my favorite movie theater memory
[Music]
that's tough
i remember seeing titanic and on a big
screen and i'm thinking
oh my god that is such an epic movie and
i also had terrible seats when i saw
titanic so i was like that the entire
time with my popcorn but i was still
there for it you're amazing yeah
first time i remember seeing a movie on
a big screen i was thinking movie called
billy jack and i should not have been
this movie seeing a movie on a big
screen seeing um
the close-ups where
the actors faces were like as big as
buicks that was the moment albeit
shouldn't have been there is when i i
think i fell in love these movies in
redding california my parents dropped us
off thinking we were going to see
101 dalmatians but we saw a movie called
shriek of fear scared the living
daylights out of us
thanks mom thanks dad i went to see the
hangover i was in north carolina
visiting some of my family me and my
cousin went together everybody was just
like talking to the movie it was a fully
interactive experience i was throwing
out jokes and people in front of me
behind me were laughing and i just had
such a good just time it was the very
first film i ever saw in a theater and
it was king kong i was amazed by the
experience i think jurassic park came
out when i was like probably 11. i
remember seeing the brontosaurus for the
first time it's just like
what i mean it just felt so real real it
was just unbelievable
[Music]
when i was about 14 lacma had an exhibit
on stanley kubrick they did a double
screening of the shining an hour of the
wolf you know still one of my favorite
directors to this day i was 11.
for my birthday party
the movie was the sound of music
singing for the children
everything the entire package it was the
best birthday party ever i went to
cinderella and on the way home i sang
all the songs and that's when i knew
this is what i was gonna do i was five
years old because with my mother we went
to see disney's tarzan and it was the
first time that i cried in a movie
theater the movie born free at the end
when elsa the lion comes back i still
remember crying
at that scene i had an aha moment when i
saw spiderman the special effects
matches now
what we imagined the comic books would
look like if they came to life my jaw
dropped
and the future for me of filmmaking
changed forever when i was 13 i was
going to see flash dance or break-in
and
after i left break-in i just immediately
started breakdancing down the street
like i was popping and locking and i do
still incorporate some of my like break
dancing moves and flash dance moves into
my current dance repertoire so beware
you